oh yes he must be on you accountant
finally yeah I hope you like your new
accounting office blended yeah we've
been without an accountant yeah things a
bit of mess around
yeah we have no idea where we are with
the finally well and after the
pleasantries let's get you all stitch
away alright pop open the cartridge slot
there on the dash Bobby open push down
on it and it will soft bill right drop
in the dictionary now you'll need to get
the cartridge the desk drawer fiber yeah
it's right underneath that okay so if
you're you're basting right way sup with
the phone facing whether the rest of the
phone facing you on your right on your
bottom right there will be a drawer that
you need to pump you need to shut kneel
down kneel down oh no it's inside the
top drawer that's where it it's not in
the desk drawer starts down there
no way no way no way Jose
no it's not that that's right we never
put things sign that no way no no boy oh
jeez oh wow oh no he's doing that it's
not even in this it's under the plan Oh
oh yeah oh we've got a phone there
that's funny
[ __ ] you you [ __ ] you post on the
cartridge in the slop now please right
right this instant we've wasted enough
time
all right finally so in a moment your PR
goggles for today is the newest craze
for the camping VR accounting is the new
your accounting speed will be
dramatically increased by the use of
these virtual reality goggles once they
pop up out of the desk just picked up
and pop them on dive right into the
number
the counting forest
very nice
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you get out of here get
the [ __ ] out of here [ __ ] you what are
you doing here my place what are you
doing at my place get the [ __ ] out of
here
you get the [ __ ] out of here what are
you doing in my place this is my tree
place this is my tree world who are you
who the [ __ ] are you to be in this place
who gives you the right to be in my
place get out of here [ __ ] you put it
back this is your place this is
my tree place my tree world who are you
who the [ __ ] are you to be in this place
who gave you the right to be in my place
you got my place get out of here this is
my tree world what do you think this is
how did you get here this is my crazy
tree world you ever hear about this this
is where my treat stop what are you
doing around here
hello who are you I am so glad to see
you thanks for being here in my dungeon
I don't know who you are but I am so
miserable and lonely by myself I'd like
you to stay forever please please hang
out so we can chat about just nonsense
and whatnot and all the fun stuff so let
me tell you about my day I woke up I
took a big poopy [ __ ] and then I just
went around the house just walking
around just walking around this dungeon
of mine just not do it I don't have much
this is why I'm sitting down right now
is why I'm laying here see I'm the king
and of this whole place and I eat
everything and I eat everything and I
don't poop for a day and you caught me
on the day that I pooped so I'm finally
exhausted today and I sat down I pet
some stuff that's oh there's my knife
thank you thank you for cleaning up my
mess ah I couldn't have done it without
you I'm so glad that you're here with me
I am so happy that you are here with me
because I thought let me tell you I have
spent the last week just eating
everything like I said just cupcakes
food garbage
I eat gone I go through garbage and
isoka like I'm so glad I have somebody
like you here in my dungeon and and to
help me just clean up everything just
just just just pick just just just just
finding my knife was with
good news we've triangulated your
position inside virtual reality and
you're literally expanding right next
you know I thought that maybe everything
would go really badly
the game virtual reality added hey dude
hey come here come here and play you
want to get up in here and play me play
me really high
you're playing this man you're playing
them good yeah those bones yeah don't
you
to the moans to the move you play those
bones down you playing the bones what
happens when you stop playing my bones
do you know what happens when you just
stop and I and I don't get to like I
don't get to say I just like just say
does it really really bugs it's a bunch
of [ __ ] you're gonna come back and
keep playing the bones man you are just
like everybody else
thank you come here your flavor you
don't blame me you come here start
picking and playing my bones you really
get me all worked up and then in these
bones came in here you came into my life
and you [ __ ] me put the acid down bro
it's great what no no no no no stop stop
no that that is that is acid like acid
burn through you did just just put it
down get away from us with that acid we
don't want nothing to do with it you put
that [ __ ] out of here do you know what
acid
here you hear ye we're in the courtroom
I'm the judge can you take off the oh my
all right okay now now that you all
right now we can get started we are a
kind people yeah we are a benevolent
people here we are just very respectable
people we are a kind people we're a
humble people and then alright okay okay
is this your first little public
defendant yes your honor I prefer the
term blue - is public defendant and I am
here to represent my client because oh
wait we don't know each other that well
you two just pick my body up I don't I
didn't sign up for this I know you were
asking for it I what do you mean I was
asking for chicken noodle soup that you
had last night you sodium puffy taco hmm
all right hello I'm sorry hello hello go
ahead with your opening statements
please all right here we go
starting now I've seen a lot of things
made of wicker a lot of wicker in the
world wicker baskets wicker chairs aha
wicker armchairs wicker stools wicker
footstool nowhere wicker comes from okay
kind of an interesting boy oh wait a
minute I've been pick I've been picked
up oh hey oh hey oh hey hello oh my god
oh my gosh swing it oh it looks okay
well you got another tourney Flo hey we
don't okay we got it
you got another tiny public defender in
there easy little public defender step
it up let's hear it all right
the art of throwing
where does one throw things and what
could one throw throw sounds a lot like
three what so boy here we go with this
again the duck oh wait a minute I've
been picked I've been picked up hey whoa
whoa you don't throw tiny public
defenders at my jury like that this is a
good jury this is a fine jury they don't
deserve these the public defender to be
thrown at them that's it I sent I hereby
with the authority of the power of the
King Kingdom of ER of the king pronounce
you to death
you're gonna die that's right it's time
to put it put put your holes life to an
end here we go bring in the guillotine
Michael oh no put on the guillotine
we're gonna load up load up the
guillotine Michael load it up just your
chat buddy
you're as dead as before now you blew it
when you could have had a shot you could
have had a shot but you don't not I'm
not anymore you couldn't listen but you
did you didn't listen nobody you didn't
you you killed the king and you're gonna
die so get in the guillotine put your
head in the guillotine
look what you did look what you did to
my world the whole forest is on fire
this was my place
this was my world grab my bomb pick up
my bomb and God protected you know don't
let the fuse get lit you gotta pick up
my bomb
reality now in reality reality
vocal technique and was just pretty
intense
believe me I need a break we weren't
gonna be able to come back from 800 you
caused a lot of suffering in there
people died this is free to thank thanks
for helping of that and yeah get to hang
out here for the rest of your life yeah
just just
we love all those little public
defenders who knows where they came from
but oh we got the whiteboard course got
the whiteboard whiteboard in there you
went into the tree guys took the battery
and let the plate on fire and all the
other creatures we've got [ __ ] another
fake would go on a statement in here a
lot of them go along pretty good I think